le temps des fêtes du service et une
période très occupée pour les banques
alimentaires qui ont du mal à fournir
tant la demande est forte producteurs
demandent de plus en plus forte à
l'année comment expliquer justement le
nombre croissant de québécois qui se
tourne et canadiens qui se tournent vers
ces banques alimentaires ce une question
à laquelle s'est penché notre invité que
je retrouve au japon oui aussi loin que
ça aujourd'hui jessica dufresne et
j'étais avocate et candidate au doctorat
en droit à l'université d'ottawa bonjour
madame dufresne
alors faisons un peu le portrait encore
cette année des banques alimentaires qui
ont lui permis d'offrir un bref répit à
de nombreuses familles pour noël mais
les besoins
je disais se font sentir vraiment à
l'année sont grandissants pourquoi une
telle demande mais on peut parler en
effet un nombre grandissant de recours
aux banques alimentaires et juste à
titre d'illustration à d'entrée de jeu
je peux vous dire que depuis 2008 depuis
la crise économique de 2008 ont fait il
ya eu une augmentation de 35% et les
recours aux banques alimentaires au
québec
et donc ça correspond le grosso modo
pour l'année 2010 est à à peu près un
million neuf cent mille de demandes
d'aidé alimentaire mensuelle de toutes
les campagnes de dons de denrées comment
on connaît avant noël les grandes lignes
au lait est-ce que c'est suffisant mais
en fait si c'est suffisant certainement
papier je pense qu'on a pu constater en
étant donné l'augmentation par contre
c'est sûr que ça répond à un besoin qui
est actuaire et en criant
donc en fait c'est une réponse qui
serait peut-être temporaire est
nécessaire je pense que cette idée est
pas de dire qu'on aurait fermé toutes
les banques alimentaires par contre on
peut se questionner à l'effet que ce
soit une réponse qu'ils soient
permanents ou durable et donc que ce que
je peux dire par contre istres et cannes
est un des aspects positifs des banques
alimentaires et de leur campagne
annuelle dans le temps des fêtes ainsi
que ça attire quand même l'attention des
médias et de la population sur le
problème de l'insécurité alimentaire qui
peut-être un peu moins présent et dans
les médias ou
- qui sait - l'automne auprès des
gouvernements pour le reste de l'année
madame france je me trompe mais ce que
je comprends de votre message c'est que
oui en plus d'être pas suffisante en
fait ces campagnes pour amasser des dons
il ya un effet pervers par rapport à la
responsabilité peut-être des
gouvernements c'est ce que vous voulez
souligné oui exactement en fait j'ai que
ça à un visibilis le problème et il ça
donne un peu l'impression que le
problème est réglé
moi quand on fait ce matin sur quoi elle
portait sur le droit à l'alimentation
oui je pense que ce que des banques
alimentaires font sens justement le
vouloir par ce qui est vraiment je pense
qu'elles les banques alimentaires comme
je dis c'est un répondre à un besoin qui
criant et elles sont nécessaires
par contre ça empêche on peut peut-être
de réaliser qu'on devrait réclamer le
droit à l'alimentation aux frais du
gouvernement droit qui que le
gouvernement du canada et du québec se
sont engagés à protéger en fait au
niveau international donc ça droit
qu'est ce que je comprends c'est que si
du jour au lendemain
les banques alimentaires dont on
comprend qu'il y aurait des conséquences
le à court terme assez important mais si
les banques alimentaires cesser leur
activité
ça obligerait les gouvernements à agir
directement c'est ce que vous voulez
dire tu as fait donc on ya des états par
exemple je pense bon brésil à l'inde en
afrique du sud à d'autres un peu moins
observé passait dans les états
occidentaux
par contre beaucoup d'états qui ont
adopté des politiques ou belloir
carrément pour protéger le droit à
l'alimentation est ce que ça implique
cpo l'idée que les citoyens pour
réclamer de l'état des aliments
directement le à l'instar de ce qui se
passe dans les banques alimentaires
par contre ce que ça fait c'est que ça
oblige les gouvernements à offrir un
environnement qui est favorable à la
réalisation du droit à l'alimentation
donc ça peut aller d'augmenter les
salaires d'adopter des lois mais loi
agricole et que c'était trop pour que
les citoyens un accès à une alimentation
qui sont en quantité et qualité
suffisantes et qui répondent à leurs
préférences des besoins alimentaires
parce qu'on était tous que dans les
banques alimentaires
c'est pas toujours de nourriture qui est
de qualité et en quantité suffisante
bon dit non en terminant quoi faire
qu'est ce qui serait des solutions
envisageables pour tendre vers ce que
vous avancez en fait peut-être une
solution transitoire ça serait de
transformer les ventes alimentaires en
acteur de ton âme isation des individus
des familles qui ont recours
donc peut-être en développement des
services plus participatif et lobo qui
permettent à la fois de répondre aux
besoins immédiats de fournir des
aliments d'urgence mais également
d'offrir des formations des cuisines
collectives du jardinage communautaire
des ateliers d'agriculture urbaine roues
des ateliers de cuisine dans les écoles
ou près des familles immigrantes
mais par contre à plus long terme je
pense que ce serait vraiment trop via
les banques alimentaires qui peuvent
être des acteurs clés doit y ait des
accords de paix doyer politique est
également devenu citoyen de prendre
conscience du droit à l'alimentation et
de le réclamer un gouvernement allait
revendre comme ça mais je pense que ça
commence
ça commence le ont fait inutilement les
gouvernements en fait je crois qu'il est
plus que nécessaire que frange à adopter
des lois et des politiques pour protéger
ce droit
chose certaine les banques alimentaires
sont extrêmement utile et très utilisés
au pays c'est ce qu'on constate d'année
en année jessica dufresne merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
je remercie la journée